cool so yeah I'm Holden if you want to
follow me on Twitter because you don't
have enough pictures of cats in your
life you can follow me on Twitter and
I'm gonna put the slides from today's
workshop and the talk I'm giving
tomorrow up on SlideShare so you don't
have to take pictures of the slides but
if you do want to take picture of one
slide this would be a good one to take a
picture of so you can find it and if you
want to connect and be all like business
business numbers I'm also on LinkedIn
like everyone else in the world but like
let me know who you are if you add me on
LinkedIn so that I can know it's
legitimate business business numbers
yeah so look I've already been
introduced so we can we can skip that
mmm let's look at art dudes out there
people still want to get the picture of
the last slide everyone ok cool so we're
gonna talk about sort of introducing
what spark is specifically what PI spark
is we're gonna talk about you know how
to get it set up we're mostly gonna
scheme through that and just do just
enough to get through the workshops
today because like deploying spark in a
real production environment can be quite
complicated and like that would take
more than that to our workshop to cover
on its own we're gonna talk about how
spark represents our distributed data
because I think it's a really cool
abstraction we have the mandatory word
count example that must be included in
every Big Data class ever I asked if I
could take it out and they said no they
would take away my Big Data license so
it's it's still here and we'll talk
about some PI sport specific things
which which is actually kind of exciting
to me because I don't normally get to
talk about these bits because I give
this sort of intro to Scala and Java
people and they get bored when they
start talking about Python and we'll
we'll look at using some different
libraries with spark and if we have time
we'll we'll talk about data frames and
we might even use some really simple
machine learning stuff so you know I'm
assuming that most people have some
interest in spark because you bothered
to show up to this talk but just in case
you wandered into the wrong talk its
spark is a really cool general-purpose
to
system it's has a wonderful API and
unfortunately that's not why most people
come to it most people come to it
because it's really fast and then they
hang around because the API isn't
terrible compared to writing MapReduce
it's like freedom it's it's I compare it
to like maybe for Trend to Python but
I've never actually had to do that
migration myself but it's it's a pretty
awesome step up from from traditional
distributed systems
it's an Apache project it's it's really
active which is both good and bad
it means it's being rapidly developed
which also means it's being rapidly
developed the core parts have API
stability now which is amazing but some
of the libraries like the machine
learning stuff are still evolving pretty
rapidly so mmm those colors do not show
up super well um but oh yeah not
supposed to wander away okay so at the
bottom it says Apache spark and you can
trust me that on top of Apache spark
there's a whole bunch of really cool
things today we're mostly gonna focus on
you know the core spark along with
sequel and data frames oh there's a
button oh now it's readable okay thank
you very much thank you okay
well now you don't have to trust me you
can trust my slides which also don't lie
so today we're gonna focus on sort of
spark sequel and data frames as well as
spark core but like all of these things
except for the community packages ship
with spark which is really cool because
if you've ever had to make like a actual
production pipeline there's a good
chance that you need to use a bunch of
different components and traditionally
these are all separate projects which
you have to glue together with something
like Luigi which I think there's another
workshop on right now which is a great
approach but I personally prefer to have
all of my code sitting together I'm
really lazy you know blessing in a curse
oh yeah and and some other cool things
about having all of these things
together as opposed to in separate
projects when sparks streaming
introduced there was a bunch of work
done to make it so that tasks could get
scheduled really quickly because that's
super important for streaming but sport
sequel was able to benefit from this as
well with sort of lower query at times
and it's just this shared work is is
really awesome so we can use like sequel
within streaming and even beyond that
like the fact that streaming got
introduced meant that a whole bunch of
stuff got made faster so this is going
to be our first sort of break to set up
I had this up on up on the slides before
if you're running Windows you probably
just want to go ahead and use the remote
azure clusters on which Microsoft has
very generously provided to us someone
pointed out to me that I put the links
and wrong and it's actually HTTP in
front of everyone rather than HTTP so
I'm really sorry about that
I should have double checked that my bad
if you can go there and just write your
name down next to a cluster so that we
don't have too many people all on like
cluster zero that would be great we have
a we have a bunch of clusters if you're
running on Linux or OSX you should feel
free to go ahead and set it up on your
local machine it's a pretty good option
too or if you already got it set up you
know you don't have to use the cluster
today we're just doing regular PI spark
we're not doing any of the really fancy
like HD inside bits but we're gonna take
a bit of time and just allow everyone to
get set up and allow me to go and drink
some more Mountain Dew and you know
maybe if the person sitting next to you
is having some difficulty getting
started you can offer to help them
because there's only one of me
and there's a lot more of you so we'll
take like 10 15 minutes and have
everyone get set up
probably closer to 10 and unless I
screwed up something else besides HTTP
and if you if you get stuck setting up
your cluster and you want to raise your
hand like I'll come over and help you
okay so hopefully most people are set up
and if you aren't you can like sort of
only half pay attention to me while I'm
talking and can
you doing the setup and will circulate
some more and answer your questions you
only need one of the remote or the local
setups if you did both that's great
extra credit not that that's really
counts for credit but you get all of the
extra credit I can give you so yeah cool
so while we're going through the
exercises today there's a bunch of
really useful links that I would keep
open there's the spark Doc's which have
sort of this general programming guide
which is pretty useful there's also the
spark pie Doc's which you know I mean so
it's pretty useful for checking the API
and I also have an iPhone notebook up on
github with the examples if you ever get
stuck I'm pretty sure they're all there
and if not I can add them so just you
know maybe take a time for few seconds
to just open these in different tabs in
Chrome or Safari or whatever Explorer
and and they'll bring this slide back up
once we once we're doing something again
so don't worry too much so if you did go
ahead and do the local installation you
can get it started with Binhai spark
this will give you a lot of log output
because the default log level is info
which is an interesting choice for
today's class actually keeping it info
can be kind of interesting because you
can see what's happening underneath the
hood with your transformations and when
spark is actually doing the work but if
on the other hand you find that this log
information is getting really annoying
there's this log4j properties template
and you should just update the the root
category to error and then you you won't
get all of these wonderful wonderful
warning messages if you're doing this in
Jupiter on on Azure everything's great
you don't have to do this don't worry
yeah don't screw up the password if
you're if you're just at the cluster
link scroll
then select notebooks and then go to
Jupiter we could reconfigure the
clusters but let's not do that because
we probably have multiple people on the
same clusters and and let's not step on
each other's toes today so we're gonna
start off by talking about the spark
context in the spark context isn't the
most exciting part of the spark world
but it's it's sort of our our entry into
things if you've looked at the HVAC
tutorial and the Jupiter you can see one
of the first things it does is create a
spark context the main thing that we use
the spark context for is creating rdd's
sparks distributed sort of data
collection and we'll talk more about how
they behave in a bit but that's the main
thing that you're gonna use the spark
context for you can create counters you
can also do broadcast variables the
spark context can be used for more than
just you know creating rdd's but that's
its main use case for today if you're
running in the shell if you run Binh PI
spark it's gonna automatically create
the spark context for you if you are
running this in the Jupiter notebook you
have to create the spark context and
some people have already noticed that we
can't have multiple spark contexts at
the same time and if you run into this
problem you can just run s-see stop and
that will shut down your existing spark
context and then you can rerun the cell
which creates your spark context the
spark context is also where we sort of
specify which cluster we're connecting
to you see this in in the HVAC example
and the jupiter notebooks where it's
pointing to the head node we can also
point it to yarn and other things like
that for today you know just use the
defaults and it's gonna work pretty well
so if you already deleted the HVAC
example from your from your jupiter
notebook this is how you can create the
spark context really quickly if you
didn't you can just use the one from the
HVAC example so with with that sort of
preliminary stuff out of the way we're
going to talk about our
and rdd's are like where I start to get
really excited about spark as opposed to
just changing configuration entries
rdd's are resilient distributed datasets
and they take a really different
approach to achieving resiliency than is
often done in distributed systems so
things like hadoop mapreduce tend to
achieve resiliency by storing the output
in multiple places so that if the node
that did the computation goes away it's
okay you can just go and read the data
from somewhere else but if anyone
remembers you know spinning disks are
really slow and even SSDs are pretty
slow and SPARC instead handles failures
through recomputing the data and it's
actually really smart SPARC is able to
only recompute the parts of the data
that it needs to since our data is
spread up on multiple machines if we
have sort of narrow transformations
that's like if we're doing things like a
map or something where like our data
only depends on this very specific
previous subset of data it will only
recompute the minimum amount required so
that's pretty awesome because
recomputing everything whenever you have
a single node failure would obviously
kind of slow you down
part of how SPARC implements rdd's is
through lazy evaluation and I normally
like to think of a panda and I'm pretty
sure I have a panda in a few slides so
we have this this panda for our lazy
evaluations so what that means is we're
not gonna do the work when we ask SPARC
to do work for us it'll just be like
haha no man I'm just gonna wait on that
until I actually need to do the work so
if we said took an RDD and let's say
complained it contained
lines of you know text and we wanted to
split it up into words we want to
tokenize it SPARC wouldn't actually do
any of the tokenization until we did
something like count the words or save
the result to a file and this is really
cool because not only does you know it
allow us to have this really cool graph
structure SPARC is able to use this
really cool graph structure to reduce
the number of times it's going to read
over the same data so it does this
really awesome pipeline
where it sticks a bunch of operations
together and that's pretty cool because
you know one of the traditional
challenges in distributed systems is
figuring out which operations I need to
stick together into the same really
giant ugly mapper and instead you know
spark just does that for me
so I'm I'm really stoked about that
that's enough sort of rambling about the
theory of rdd's let's look at you know
making a really really simple word count
example that I you know have to do or
they take my Big Data license away from
me so the first thing that we do is we
make this RTD of lines and so what that
means is that we have this really cool
distributed collection and it consists
of just lines of text so SC text file
gives us a really convenient wrapper to
load in text data we can load in any
other types of data that are supported
by Hadoop and we don't need like a
Hadoop cluster it just can understand
that stuff but this this makes it really
simple for handling text data the flat
map and the lambda function inside
should be pretty familiar since we're
all like Python people and then we have
this word counter example which is
actually incorrectly formatted because
I'm the best at slides and what we do is
we take each word and we put the number
one next to it and then we have this
reduction which says I want to take all
of the things with the same word and I
want to sum the values and this is this
is really cool because it's lazy and
this reduced by key as actually does a
whole bunch of really cool things behind
the scenes if you're coming from
MapReduce and I know I keep talking
about it and it's not that I hate my
produce I love it it's just I think
spark is more awesome it automatically
does a map side combined so what that
means is before it goes ahead and
shuffles the data across the network it
figures out you know all of the things
with the same word that happened to be
on the same machine that I'm processing
at the start it'll do that reduction
first and it does that automatically for
us and then you know later on it'll do
the shuffle and we'll have much less
network traffic which is cool because
network traffic is kind of expensive
so as I was saying spark is lazy and our
magic line of laziness is right above
save as file all of the things prior to
it are lazy transformations text file
you know maybe not a transformation
since it's not taking an RDD and giving
us back another RTD but it's still lazy
we don't actually read the data until we
go ahead and save the output which means
you can write like a really really long
giant transformation then go ahead and
like do your action at the end and find
out that the data you were doing it on
doesn't actually exist so it's it's good
to do things in things like notebooks
where it's really simple to go back up
and and change something otherwise
you'll find yourself you know being kind
of sad sometimes another thing was
really important to understand while
we're looking at this example is that
all of these operations are actually
giving us back new rdd's we're not
transforming the existing data or well
we are but it doesn't change it in place
right so lines is still just an RDD of
lines so it's actually pretty common in
spark to read in some data and then do a
bunch of different operations on it and
we'll have this shared common lineage
and that's totally ok and it's actually
really great because we can use caching
to make it extra fast so I mean this is
this is our wonderful panda with some
pretty common transformations especially
if you're coming from a functional
programming background we've got map
which allows us to produce a new value
for every input value we've got filter
so that we can only process the lines
which talk about how awesome we are
we've got flat map for tokenizing things
reduced by key is pretty neat
so that we can actually combine values
with the same key you know distributed
systems and join in Co group are
actually also transformations even
though they work on multiple rdd's
there's still transformations they're
taking in rdd's and giving us back our
Dedes and they're lazily evaluated too
so they won't explode and give us an
our message until much later but at the
same time it is able to do a lot of sort
of optimizations around it's one thing
to understand about the the first few
transformations is that there are narrow
transformations and what this means is
that since the output data has a sort of
very direct mapping to the input data
spark is able to really easily recompute
data when it gets lost so if a worker
node fails and we lost some you know
data from a narrow transformation we
have a really small bit of recompute to
do but joins you know we might have to
recompute a lot of data so sometimes it
can be a good idea to like cache stuff
on multiple nodes after doing joins if
you know you're going to be doing a
really long term computation so actions
are our eager-beaver
and I'm Canadian so I like this beaver
so count reduce collect take um the
important thing to note is that reduce
is an action and reduce by key is a
transformation that's because reduce is
going to return a single value to our
driver program or rather than returning
another distributed collection collect
is great it brings the values back to
our driver and then makes it promptly
fall over because we tried to bring a
terabyte of data back to a laptop but
it's really useful in unit testing if
you're doing other you know sort of more
production type stuff you're probably
more interested in take where you can
grab a few things and there's also take
sample if you just want to sample your
data the actual output mechanisms that
you probably want to use are like save
as text file and then there's also save
as to do although like the saving to
sequence files from Python is a little
funky but so like saving to JSON is
probably like a much better idea than
trying to do the Python sequence files
they're a little weird and count by
value is great it's like collect in that
we could make our thing fall over but we
might not if we don't have too many
distinct values it's the Russian
Roulette of Python programming
so okay with that I've given you like an
incredibly fast introduction to rdd's
and only a few transformations and
actions but we're gonna exercise like
this dog which is jumping over to pretty
low bars but you know it's actually
gonna be challenging for us because it's
probably our first time doing it just
like I imagine is this puppy's first
time jumping over those two bars so
we're gonna go ahead and we're gonna
find all of the lines with the word
spark and then we're gonna count them
and so this is this is the first part
and this is the part that just you know
so that we can all be working from the
same input data normally we wouldn't be
reading it from a file right we'd be
reading it well we'd be reading it from
industry we did file but I was kind of
lazy and I didn't want to put a big data
set up for us to work on and I also
wanted things to move quickly so we'll
do it from a local file but this could
just as easily be data on HDFS so yeah
go ahead
and let's find the lines with the word
spark and I'll jump back a few slides to
the to the links that we can use if we
get lost on what sort of transformations
and actions we might want to use to do
this
if you're doing this in the azure
cluster feel free to do this on top of
the HVAC tutorial just make sure to do
it with a new cell rather than in the
same cell that is creating your spark
contacts because we can only have one
spark contacts at a time or you can you
know do the work to create your own
spark contacts in a separate notebook
either way is fine how many people have
a word count for the number of words and
spark sorry for the number of lines with
spark okay cool
how many people want five more minutes
okay I'm sorry there's only one of you
will look at the solution and you know
that should that should help solutions
tend to help so I mean this is one of
many solutions you can write your lambda
function in different ways and and this
will be in the ipython notebook as well
if you want so what we're doing is we're
reading in our data and then we're
filtering for only the lines which
contain the word spark and then we're
calling count now we could call collect
and then do like a count on their array
that we get back that works because our
data is actually pretty small but you
know generally we might have larger data
so calling count is better because what
happens is each worker will figure out
the number of entries that are there and
only return the number of entries to the
driver and that'll definitely fit on the
driver and we could also save an RDD um
you have a question oh yeah yeah that's
a typo Thanks doo doo doo doo doo doo
oh damn ah okay cool
now with slightly less typos sorry if
the type was tripping anyone up that was
looking at the at the slides to get
ahead sorry so one thing that we could
do is we could combine the solution with
also doing another thing on that same
file right like we could count the
number of lines not containing spark or
we could you know count the total number
of lines we could save the word count we
could we could do all of these things
now admittedly I do have the answer up
here but does anyone want to pretend
that they haven't read the slide and and
say you know what they think might
happen you have to not be looking at the
slide to pretend you didn't read it okay
no one wants to do that okay um but so
essentially if we do two actions on the
same RDD or we do two actions on
different rdd's which share the same
parent will actually end up doing the
work to compute that parent multiple
times and like that's not great you know
be cool if like that was magically
figured out for us it's not currently
but for now if we know that we're gonna
be reusing the same data on multiple
times like let's say we're training a
linear regression model we know we're
gonna be iterating on our training data
set a few times we would go ahead and we
would cache that data and caching is
awesome we have a few different options
for for how we can catch our data we can
catch our data in memory which is great
because it's really fast we can catch
our data to disk which is cool cuz
there's a lot of it or we can catch our
data in memory and disk which is great
cuz it's really fast but if we run out
of space it's still there and it's
normally faster to read the data from a
local disk than it is from say HDFS
this isn't always true if your cluster
has especially terrible drives you know
never cashed a disk but maybe get a
better cluster whatever and and the
third option is checkpointing so if
we're doing like really really complex
work right and it would be it would be
so bad if we lost a node to recompute
this data we can actually do what sort
of MapReduce would do and write it out
to HDFS or a persistent store and this
is actually really useful in some graph
type computations because when you're
doing these really really long graph
computations we're building up this
giant graph of all of the information
that is needed to construct this RDD and
keeping that in memory can get kind of
expensive but if you can put it in like
this persistent storage space SPARC can
just forget about all of that stuff and
then you can just keep working from this
persistent storage going forward so you
know a little bit of a side note but I'm
talking so I got to make side notes yeah
okay so if we pretended that I hadn't
put the answer on the previous slide we
could we could you know investigate this
with two debug string and this is
actually something you can do on the
rdd's from the previous exercise that we
were doing you won't be able to do this
on the collected or counted value
because that's a that's a local value
but on any of the distributed
collections the rdd's you can do to
debug string and we get to see this
information about where our data is
coming from right so we can see here
that my home directory is home holden
not the most imaginative but like you
can see what your what your backing path
was for all of your data we can see that
there's a shuffle involved right and you
know it's this is interesting it's not
super interesting for word count to be
fair but for other things it can be it
can be much more informative when when
things are behaving weirdly and you
don't know what's going on
so this is this is with a cached version
you can see we have this information
about you know we cache two partitions
this is the amount of memory it took etc
I haven't really talked about partitions
too much / at all because we can write
code and pretend they don't exist but if
anyone's been wondering sort of how
SPARC decides where the data goes on two
different machines there's this really
cool thing called partitions and by
default you know spark will try and when
you're reading in the data read it in
from a node that is close to the node
with the data and it'll distribute this
on like a bunch of machines but if we
like aren't doing a bunch of drawings
between data we can specify like a
certain partition ER and then spark is
able to use that information to make our
join super fast and there's a bunch of
other reasons to do custom partitioning
like secondary sorting but you know we
don't have to worry about that today
cool so it's time for a detour into the
internals and proof that I know how to
use flickers licensed for commercial use
filter so we've actually already
explained most of what lazy evaluation
is and some people have probably already
come across the last problem right how
many people got error messages that were
pointing them to not at all the right
line while they were working on this I
know there was at least one of you
raised your hand okay - - so okay for
for a program this small it's pretty
simple to figure out where things are
going wrong right like there's just not
that much going on but you know the lazy
evaluation with a really big program can
make it kind of you know tricky to
figure out where things are actually
failing especially in Python where the
error messages are a mixture of Python
stack traces and Java stack traces which
is sometimes confusing even to me right
and I work on this sometimes I find it's
really useful to like do a take 1 or or
head on some of the rdd's when I come
into like a failure and I want to try
and figure out like what is actually
failing
you know use that as you may we've
talked about how spark is able to do the
pipelining and how that's really awesome
but like the pipelining is more than
just making stuff fast it actually makes
some things possible that you know well
I mean it makes us writing bad code
possible which is good because bad code
is often faster but what I mean by that
is like we can write things which would
result in materializing stuff which is
too big and provided that we're doing
these right kinds of transformations
spark is able to just like put it
together and like do really intelligent
pipelining this is this is cool
especially when we're dealing with
things which are difficult to serialize
because there's some serialization
restrictions and this comes up more in
the Scala side than the Python side but
you know if anyone converts you to the
dark side of the JVM remember this so we
ran some code right and we didn't put a
cache in there but I'm gonna pretend
that we did put a cache in there and
let's look at what's happening so I'm
also gonna pretend we're reading in from
you know a distributed data store as
opposed to local machine so this is not
exactly this code but some code so our
driver program is gonna like take our
work and it's going to serialize our
function and send it across to the
worker this can actually be like an
interesting source of bugs if you ever
write code and you start getting
serialization errors there's a few
chances of things that could be going
wrong you could be trying to return or
read something that isn't serializable
or if your function is referencing like
something in your outer class spark
we'll try and grab that entire class and
serialize it
that's works like some of the time but
it's kind of slow and other times it'll
also fail because your class like has
some non serializable elements in it so
that's something to watch out for so we
send our function to our workers our
workers are going to read a bunch of
data they're gonna send the counts back
and they're also going to have this
little cached partition and this cache
partition could be living in memory
could be living on
depending on what we said we could also
if we're worried about node failure ask
spark to cache the data on multiple
machines and this will still normally be
faster than checkpointing because
writing to another spark worker is
generally faster than writing to HDFS
but so it's that's pretty simple and the
cool thing is now if we went back and we
did like the same operation or we did
something similar we wouldn't have to
read the data in again cool okay so now
I get to do something that I don't
normally get to do which is talk about
high spark internals so spark is
primarily written in Scala but you know
we we're using it Python you know how is
how is this magic working and it's not
JSON because our code is running or more
specifically we're able to call like you
know panda's libraries and stuff like
that like useful things that might not
be available in JSON and so spark does
this by starting up native Python
processes and then using PI for J how
many people have used PI for J I'm sorry
to both of you but why for J when it
works is really pretty simple
conceptually you can think of it as just
like making a pipe and we're we're
asking the JVM to do things for us
sometimes and the JVM will if it's
feeling in the mood send back some data
or a stack trace so that's that's sort
of how the integration is done there and
that's pretty cool but spark still needs
the data to live in the JVM right like
all of our shuffle operations all of our
caching all of our partitioning stuff
that's all done in Scala so we use
pickling how many people have pickled
all of their data once again I'm sorry
to about three people so we can think of
it as like serializing all of our data
so like if you've hmm you could think of
it
yeah we're actually using pickling for
our cross process communication pickling
everything is kind of slow right we're
having to take all of our stuff and
serialize it and then deserialize it
repeatedly the cool thing is sparks
equal actually avoid some of this which
is pretty cool and and sparks equal and
data frames are going to use those terms
interchangeably because Michael isn't in
the room and he won't like glare at me
but if he's watching the YouTube video
I'm sorry
but anyway so sparks equal lets us work
with structured data and the structured
data lives in the jvm land for as long
as possible until we actually need to do
something really Python specific so
until we're doing like a lambda function
on it so we could do our filters and
stuff you know if they were simple
enough and still keep the data in the
JVM let's get this yeah so I've been
talking about how we can use other
libraries but we haven't actually used
them today and realistically we're
probably not because there's only so
much time but there's a bunch of
different libraries that we can use with
spark right in addition to the things
that spark itself ships with there's a
wonderful collection of libraries on
spark packages org and I'm not saying
this just because I have a package on
spark packages org I actually use other
people's packages from there there's
things like reading in from different
file formats there's stuff like making
it possible to test your code which is
cool testing is awesome and there's
tools to do like different types of like
machine learning stuff that isn't maybe
an ml libs yet so SPARC packages is a
great source but I mean we're all here
because we like Python right and we're
probably familiar with Python tools
rather than spark tools so we should try
and use those tools when we can so we've
got a few options to to make our our
Python packages available one option is
honestly and it's if
you control your cluster just
pre-installing it and on all of your
worker nodes is a pretty good approach
it works like 80 90 percent of the time
the other option is if you have like a
zip file or egg distribution of your
Python stuff you can add it with you
know speccing specifying zip files when
you're starting your PI spark job if
you're doing it in Jupiter or something
like that there's also some parameters
that you can set that are similar and
you can find them in the documentation
and another one is you can also
dynamically add more Python code with SC
dot oh wait no that is not right it's
not SCO add file it says C dot something
I'll correct that on the slides when
they finally go up but you could use add
file I guess just don't um there's
something better and it'll be on the
finished slides I'm sorry about that
typo number two but anyways yeah so
there's a bunch of ways we can go about
you know using these other libraries if
you've got it you know if you go out
your cluster and you have admin access
just just pretty install it it's just so
much simpler so we're gonna go ahead and
we're gonna take Sparks data frames out
for a spin
they're amazing in quite a lot of ways
but it's really important to remember
that they're not really maybe what you
would have come to expect if you're
coming from our or pandas like the
operations that we can do on them are
not as full-featured relatedly I have a
talk tomorrow on how to do more awesome
things with spark data frames using
sparkling pandas if anyone wants to come
to that you know I think it's cool but
I'm obviously pretty biased one of the
things that I love about spark data
frames and I mean this is kind of silly
but it has saved my bacon so many times
is support for schema inference on JSON
how many people have to work with
structured JSON data a lot of people in
this room are really lucky normally way
more people are having to work with
terrible data format
but if you're having to work with
structured JSON which no one bothered to
write down what the format was ever
spark schema inference on JSON is
amazing you can just point it at that
like your giant giant JSON for like two
years worth of server logs and it just
it's amazing I'm sorry I can't it's just
saved me so much time it's hard to not
talk about it even though there's only a
few people it'll benefit so the the
final thing is that we access spark data
frames through the sequel context if you
were looking at the HVAC example you
notice that after we made the spark
context it was making the sequel context
so we'll do something similar oh yeah
let's not use this one so data frames
aren't quite as lazy as rdd's and part
of this is the magic of schema inference
right like when we're loading our data
data frames are structured so they try
and figure out some of the schema
information what this means is you know
you're not going to get an error message
that the file that you thought you were
processing doesn't exist but it won't be
quite as lazy like you'll see some
computation happening as you're going
well rest assured that it's it's
actually delaying most of the
computation so here here's some sample
JSON schema as inferred by spark I mean
not the prettiest thing in the world but
compared to staring at like a hundred
records and trying to manually guess
what it is oh my god so we can get this
by calling print schema on on a data
frame and we can do this with more than
just JSON data
it's just JSON data tends to be
especially like gnarly so we've got like
some different ways we can manipulate
data frames we can go ahead and actually
just write pure sequel against it
many people know sequel Oh finally
okay the first time there's more than
like three hands going up in their room
okay cool
how many people like sequel cool okay
okay there's there's some people on the
fence but like you know compared to
Fortran how many people like sequel oh
wow
less people okay okay sorry but sparks
sequel lets us take these data frames
and we can write sequel queries against
them so as you can see I like pandas and
I especially like this panda ID I don't
remember what it is but that's the one
I'm looking for the other option is we
can write things with this sort of more
programmatic style API and this is just
a DF dog filter and it works like normal
but it's pretty cool because and and
like don't hate me for saying this the
data doesn't have to come to Python and
it's not that I don't like Python it's
just that I don't like serializing
objects so we're able to do this
operation while keeping all of our data
in the JVM narrow it down to something
much smaller and then working it with it
in Python so I think it's pretty cool
yeah okay cool
so that being said at some point we're
all Python programmers we're probably
gonna want to write some Python code so
we can actually just call map on it and
so we can go ahead and like this says
I'm getting the the text information
from each row and this just gives me
back a regular RTD right like it's no
longer a special data frame it's just
it's just an RDD and all of the things
we were doing before will now work on it
if we have an RDD we can also convert it
back to a data frame or it doesn't even
have to be from a data frame we can we
can manually specify a schema or have a
spark magically and for a schema for us
we can also make UDF's right that's
another option for when we want to run
some Python code in on top of our data
frames
and I mean this might not look that
pretty but compared to writing a hive
UDF this is amazing how many people have
written a hive UDF oh man tough crowd
okay so um trust me when I say even
though we're having to specify our
return type here this is way better than
having to write UDF's and many other
sort of distributed systems right we
just write some really simple Python
code we say what our name is gonna be
and we say this is our return type and
it's it's just magic cool um so it's
time for one more exercise and me to go
get some more Mountain Dew and probably
something from my throat because I've
been talking away too much I'm sorry
we're gonna go ahead and write a UDF to
compute the length of a tweet this isn't
actually really gonna be a tweet like
it's well it'll be one of my like
useless tweets but we're just gonna
write a UDF to compute the length of a
string yeah cool so that being said
right you know I'm asking you to do
something but we don't have any tweets
right now right like unless you work at
Twitter
in which case let's talk I want some of
your data we need to collect some tweets
so we've got some options to get some
tweets the first one is if you have your
Twitter credentials handy there's a
really cool spark streaming demo which
will actually just go ahead and collect
some tweets for us so if you want to
play around with that be my guest and we
can we can chat about how that works
normally we'd have a bunch of tweets
collected on HDFS I'm pretty lazy though
so I'm just gonna have you get them from
my github well actually from the data
breaks github so yeah we can we can do
this so let's let's walk through this
code the first part is importing URL to
which should be pretty familiar then we
just go ahead and fetch it we're not
using spark yet I'm printing out the
data to make sure that like I actually
got some data and here I'm saving it to
a local file
in this case actually this is like a
really specific one you can see magic -
is is probably not actually where you
want to save your data but you can just
go ahead and like save it to a local
file or there should also be some
information in the spreadsheet and if
there isn't I'll go ahead and add it
right now about which where you're
distributed storages and you can save it
to the distributed storage and then just
work with us like normal you'll note I
haven't actually showed you how to load
the JSON data so this is one of those
examples where we get to look at the
documentation and and figure it out I'm
both optimistic and scared but I think
the spark documentation is pretty good
and we should all be able to you know
figure this out from the docs and if we
can't no worries like just raise your
hand
and and I can come help guide people in
the docs and I'll probably go ahead and
update that spreadsheet right now with
with people's storage credentials and
then I'll go get some Mountain Dew
so the storage info is in a separate tab
on the PI data pipe spark clusters dock
called storage info and I'll put some
paths on there one thing to keep in mind
is with spark when we go ahead to save a
file out it won't by default overwrite
in an existing file so like put your
name or something in the path that
you're writing it out so you're not
stepping on each other's toes
so one option is we don't have to
specify the full path we can actually
just specify the file name and it all
got written to hdinsight I forgot about
that but it's awesome it's super happy
fun times so if you were getting lost
trying to figure out like what your
credentials were just go ahead and save
it to just a file and don't put like
file colon slash slash in front of it
like that'll try and save it to local
disk and that's not what we want
okay so we're getting close to the end
of our wonderful time together it's it's
been great hanging out with all of you
and you should come and find me more I
have pretty distinctive hair so I
shouldn't be the hardest person to find
here but there might be another person
with rainbow hair so like double check
my name is Holden before we all run away
I wanted to talk about some additional
resources so that you can continue your
adventure with learning spark because I
know you are all incredibly excited and
want to learn more about spark so we've
we've been looking at the docs a lot
today they're pretty good there's also
some ebooks and I'm a little biased
because I've written some spark books I
think they're all excellent and everyone
should own several copies but yeah let's
let's look at some of the stuff so the
learning spark book is one of the books
I co-wrote I think it's really good but
obviously I'm incredibly biased here
there's also fast data processing with
spark make sure you get the second
edition I get less money when you get
the second edition because someone else
like updated it but the first edition is
like terribly out of date so unless you
are like interested in learning how
sparks API has evolved over time
you probably want the second edition of
fascinator processing with spark or the
learning spark book both are on the
really new spark stuff
there's a wonderful advanced analytics
book by Sandy and some other wonderful
people at Cloudera and spark and action
is supposed to be coming soon I know
they they switched authors and I don't
actually remember who the new people are
but it'll probably have pretty
up-to-date API coverage once it comes
out too so that's that's another thing
to look at we're all at a conference
because conferences are awesome and an
excuse to get out of our workplace
there's some other fun
conferences coming up and meetups -
strata in Hadoop world in New York I'll
be giving a talk there I wasn't able to
convince my employer to send me to
Amsterdam but if you can convince your
employer to send you to Amsterdam more
power to you there's a spark summit in
Amsterdam and I will be really jealous
please send me pictures there's also a
Seattle spark meetup I've never been but
I assume it's pretty good it looks kind
of cool and there's a lot more community
events as well also on the SPARC website
there's a bunch of videos on Apache
spark there's there's this YouTube
channel which is pretty good it has a
lot of the things from the previous sort
of trainings and also previous talks on
spark there's there's a training of
spark summit and there's also a video of
the 2014 training things have changed a
bit but not that much it's still pretty
good
Paco also has a wonderful introduction
to spark which is great if you have $100
or an expense account it's it's pretty
good too and you can get it from
O'Reilly and yeah that's pretty much it
I you know thanks for hanging out with
me for two hours I know it's been a long
time
I really really want to thank all of the
people from Microsoft if you want to
come up maybe and and say who you are
that would be cool but you don't have to
oh that's a no yes yes yay but the
Microsoft people have been super awesome
and helpful with getting getting our
clusters set up they gave us this this
cluster space for free
they're amazing - do you maybe want to
like yeah so I'm Alejandra and I am
working on a chain inside which is the
team that provided the clusters that you
were using today if you have any
feedback please let us know and I hope
that it all about everything work for
you hi my name is Judy I also work on
the spark crew um and idea starting I'm
a spark contributor right now and yes we
are love love-love-love feedback from
you guys to make our pride of much
better thank you